- Well hi, to celebrate the season I put together
MAHOMES FOR THE HOLIDAYS!
Songs sung by me and all of my best friends.
[Singing] MCCOY TO THE WORLD, THE RUN HAS COME.
WITH HITS SUCH AS—
[Singing] - LE’VEON BELL, LE’VEON BELL
LE’VEON BELL IS OUT.
Oh what fun it is to bowl Instead of running routes.
- Hey.
[Singing] - Vrabel, Vrabel, Vrabel, you look good on game day.
[Singing] - AWAY GAMES ARE DANGER,
BUT THE SEAHAWKS ARE S--T.
[Singing] - God tests yee, David Gettleman
You sent Odell away...
[Singing] - Let old opponents be forgot
cuz we got a first-round bye!
- We even have a special song from “CAT TEAMS: THE MUSICAL”!
[Singing] - CAT TEAMS! WE GO PURR, PURR!
CAT TEAMS! THE SEASON’S A BLUR, BLUR.
- AND MANY MORE!
- WOW!
EVERYBODY!
- [All together singing:] THE CURSED O-DELL—
- Happy holidays everyone and please subscribe to this channel.
Before you do, here's a little diddy for you.
[Singing] Deck them all as respectfully as possible
Luke, Luke, Luke, Luke, Luke, Luke, Luke Keuchly